ممنوع من نشر قضيته على وسائل التواصل
وايلون ماس يثير الجدل مجددا لا للحسابات
غير نشطه ويوم النصر في روسيا واوكرانيا
لا نصر في اهلا بكم الى تفاعلكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم يعودوا الرئيس الامريكي السابق
والمرشح للرئاسه دونالد ترامب ليتصدر
الاخبار في القضيه الجنائيه التي يواجهها
بتهمه تزوير سجلات تجاريه مقابل دفع اموال
لشراء صمت الممثله الاباحيه
انتخابات 2016 الجديد هو اصدار القاضي
اخوان مرشن امر تقييدا بحق ترامب في
الوصول الى الادله التي تم تسليمها الى
فريقه من نسخ او نشر او كشف اي ادله في
القضيه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي من
دون الحصول على موافقه من المحكمه ولا
يمكن للترامب ان يطلع على اي معلومات
حساسه بخصوص هذه القضيه من دون حضور
محاميه ولا يسمح له كذلك بحيازه اي دليل
بصوره مستقله وطلب مكتب المتجر العام في
منهات امر الحمايه هذا بسبب مخاوف من ان
ترامب قد يستخدم تلك الادله بشكل غير لائق
او ينشر المعلومات على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي او في مكان اخر
يجد في منصاته تشوز سوشل ملاذا يشارك من
خلالها كل ما يدور في راسه وما يواجهه مع
الملايين من متابعين
طبعا عرض محامو ترامب هذا الامر كولان
الوثائق والمراسلات وغيرها تعتبر من
العناصر المتبادله بين الاطراف المتنازعه
في قضيه قانونيه قبل المحاكمه وانتهاك لحق
ترامب مشاهدينا لتذكير ترامب كان قد مثل
امام المحكمه الشهر الماضي في منهاتن
للتحقيق معه في 34 تهمه جنائيه وذلك بخصوص
شرائه الصمت
مقابل
130 الف دولار قبل الانتخابات الرئاسيه في
2016 المبلغ كان قد دفعه محامي ترامب
السابق مايكل كوهن والذي اعترف بالامر لكن
ترامب كان قد اكد ان الاموال كانت مقابل
نفقات قانونيه للعمل وكان قد نفى كل هذه
التهم الموجهه ضده هذا تطور يجعلنا تساءل
ان كانت قضيه الاحتيال المحاسبيه
والضريبيه هذه وغيرها من القضايا المتهم
فيها ترامب والتي كان اخرها اتهامه من قبل
الكاتبه الامريكيه اي جين كارول اغتصابها
وتشويه سمعتها ستعرقل نجاح ترامب في
الانتخابات ام انها لن تؤثر عليه وانما
بالعكس ربما تثبت براءته قبل الانتخابات
وتزيد من شعبيته اذا الاسئله كثيره تدور
حول مصير الرئيس الاكثر جدليه في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده على كل هذه الاسئله كلها
للاجابه عليها ينضم الينا من جده الدكتور
بندر الدوشي الباحث الشان الامريكي دكتور
اهلا بك معنا في تفاعلكم وفي العربيه
يتخذ من منصاته
ليشارك ملايين من متابعي على هذه المنصه
كل ما يدور في راسه اولا هذا القرار
بتقييد وصوله الى الادله الجنائيه الى هو
مبرر
نعم حياكم الله اولا يجب
قضيه خطيره واتهام غير مسبوق لشخصيه
سياسيه متنافسه او تنافس
خصم سياسي يونافس الرئيس الامريكي الحالي
وبالتالي ما يحدث هو اصلا ما يحدث هو نوع
من الاضطهاد السياسي ثم بعد ذلك كان
متوقعا ايضا تقييد الرئيس الامريكي السابق
من الحديث حول هذه القضيه
ومنع النشر في هذا المجال واعتقد ان هناك
عده جوانب في هذا
الجانب الاول هو ان
الديمقراطيه يريدون ان ما يحدث الان من
تقييد الحديث هو نوع من استبات للاحداث
لمحاكمه المقبله
يريدون الديمقراطيين ان يظهر الرئيس
الامريكي السابق ان لا يظهر الرئيس
الامريكي مظهر الضحيه تراب نجح في استغلال
هذه القضيه نجاحا باهر اصدر عده اعلانات
وعده دعايه بانه يتعرض للقياس سياسي كبير
وانما يحدث هو مطارده للساحرات وبالتالي
هذه القضيه ربما من وجهه نظري اثرت او
ساهمت في بروز نجم ترامب مجددا
نلاحظ ان في اخر استطلاع للرائي بين
ترامبس المرشح الجمهوري القوي ايضا
النطرون يوسع الفارك الى 40 نقطه
الاستطلاع الخطير الذي يراه الديمقراطي
بحسب وجهه نظري بالنتيجه الخطيره هو ما
حدث في استطلاع واشنطن بوست حيث حيث اظهر
استطلاعب يتقدم على ثمانيه نقاط وهو وهي
نتيجه غير مسبوقه واعتقد ان هناك نوع من
الطوار
الديمقراطي لماذا هذه النتيجه هناك موصف
فان النتيجه نوع من التعذيب للديمقراطيين
وان هناك يجب ان تبحث الحزب الديمقراطي ما
نبحث عن استراتيجيه او النظر وراع الاسباب
التي دفعت بالمستقلين والمعتدلين
المعتدلين الحزب الجمهوري الالتصاق
بالترام ودعمه في امام
هذا هذا بالنسبه لساحه المعترك السياسي
على ساحه مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ترامب
يملك 146 مليون متابع على مواقع التواصل
بينها 5 ملايين متابع على منصه تشيلسوشيال
التي ينشط فيها اليوم الى اي مدى مواقع
التواصل اليوم قد تكون محفز للترامب وقد
تكون خادمه لترامب بهدف الوصول للرئاسه في
[موسيقى]
اجتماعيه ترام شخصيه وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تبحث عن عوده الترامب واين
تويتر كيف اعادت رمل وكيف ان ايلون ماسك
كان ينحني الى ترامب للرغبه في عادته
لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي للرغبه في البدء
بالتغريد مجددا فيسبوك اعاده رمل يوتيوب
اعاده رمل هو وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي من غير
مجدي او غير متفاعله ترامب هو من يحيي
تويتر وهو من يبحث عنه ماسك الان ترامب في
منصه
فعال في عرض قضيته في عرض مظلوميته في
مهاجمه دي سانتوس في مهاجمه الديمقراطيه
في مهاجمه اليسار وبالتالي القضيه الاكبر
التي بوينت التي ستقوم مؤثره
القويه او في جانب تمام هو متى يبدا
بالتغريد العوده الى التغريد في حساب
تويتر نعرف ان حسابه في تويتر مال مليون
يعني ملايين
المتابعين من حول العالم يتابعون الرئيس
الامريكي وبالتالي تاثيره هاي على تويتر
واعتقد انه
سيكون من
المفاجئ جدا ان يستخدم تويتر لكن هو يريد
هو استثمر كثيرا في السوشيال منصه التواصل
الاجتماعي وبالتالي هو يريد نجاح هذه
المنصه لكن اعتقد اننا من عوده الى تويتر
اذا اراد الفوز بالرئاسه الامريكيه مجددا
للعمل
من استخدام تويتر وفيسبوك عقباء او عقاب
واقعه اليوم اختار ان ينشط في منصته
الجديده لكنه كذلك يتهم باستخدام خطاب
العنف والكراهيه كيف تصفون سلوك ترامب على
مواقع التواصل باختصار
ترامب هو مشكله نفسه
لا يستطيع التحكم في سلوكه سلوك ترامب هو
ما ابعد عنه خبيرا المعتدلين في عام 2020
واذا ارادت رمى العوده الى الرياسه عام
2024 عليه ان يضبط سلوك عليه ضبط خطابي
المتهور ضد الخصوم عليهم
ان يمنع مع نفسه من التحدث في قضايا ليس
له علاقه في الحديث وبالتالي اعتقد ان
الجمهوريون هناك من الاستراتيجيه يعتبرون
ان التعرم على تويتر هذه الايام ونعم وهم
لا يريدون ترامب العوده الى تويتر واثاره
القضايا الجدليه مجددا هو الان يتقدم في
استطلاعات الراي الجميع مرتاح بهذا المسلك
لكن الديمقراطيين في اعتقادي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد لاغنى رجل في العالم
ولمالك تويتر والرئيس التنفيذي مليار
ايلون من اخباري تفاعلكم اليوم فماسك من
بدايه امتلاكه لمنصه تويتر اجرى الكثير من
التغييرات فيها بدءا من تسريح الموظفين
مرورا برسوم التوثيق وانتهاء بسياسات
جديده لتويتر احدث ما اعلن عنه ماسك هو
حذف الحسابات غير النشطه على تويتر فكتب
في تغريده ان تويتر سيقوم بحذف كل
الحسابات التي لم تسجل دخولا الى تويتر
وغير النشطه منذ سنوات حيث تنص السياسه
الجديده لتويتر على ضروره ان يقوم صاحب
الحساب بتسجيل الدخول كل ثلاثين يوما على
الاقل للحفاظ على حسابه وهذه العمليه في
حال بدات ستكون اكبر عمليه حذف للحسابات
منصات تويتر حيث قال ماسكنا الكثير من
مستخدمي تويتر سيلاحظون انخفاضا في عدد
المتابعين في حساباتهم وهذه النقطه تخوف
منها الكثير من مستخدمي تويتر وفي رده على
المنتقدين لهذا القرار والذي اكد ان هناك
الكثير من الحسابات القديمه تحوي تغريدات
تاريخيه يحبها الناس ويرجعون اليها كل
فتره قلماسك ان تلك الحسابات سيتم ارشفتها
وليس حطفها وهنا لابد ان نشير الى هذه
العمليه جزء من عمليه توثيق الحسابات
والتاكد منها والحد من الحسابات الوهميه
التي تعاني منها منصات تويتر وكل
الاجراءات التي يقوم بها ماسك يسعى من
خلالها لرفع ايرادات تويتر وتحسين الوضع
الحالي للمنصه ومنها اعلان دعمه لمنشئي
المحتوى على تويتر فنشر تغريده تنقل فيها
الى تويتر يدعم منشئي المحتوى ولن يحصل
على ارباح من ايراداتهم في العام الاول من
اشتراكهم في تويتر وبعدها سياخذ تويتر 10%
فقط من الارباح
عبر زوم ينضم الينا من دبي نسل المرعى
للمتخصص في الشؤون المعلوماتيه والتقنيه
اهلا بك انس معنا في تفاعلكم وفي العربيه
يعني احدث التغييرات والسياسات الجديده
لماسك على تويتر هي حذف الحسابات غير
النشطه منذ سنوات كيف تقراون هذا القرار
اولا
مساء الخير ولجميع المشاهدين بالضبط مثل
ما تفضلتي هو في الرد على اجابته لاحدى
المنتقدين المعروفين او احدى كبار
الشخصيات على تويتر قال بانه سوف يتم
ارشفتها ولو نظرنا لكلمه ارشفتها كان ممكن
ما تكون بالضروره تعني هذه الحسابات وعلى
سيره حذف الحسابات بنعرف انه كانت مشكله
كبيره في
شراء صفقه تويتر وكان لهن مسك واحد من اهم
يعني هو
الوحده من اهم مشاكله اللي هي الحسابات
اللي الوهميه اللي بتنشئها البوت فهو بهاي
الطريقه عم بحاول يمشي مع التيار ويمشي
فقط حتى نفهم من الناحيه التقنيه ما الفرق
بين ارشفتها وحذف وكيف يمكن لمستخدمي
تويتر ان يصلوا الحسابات المؤرشفه
نعم لحد الان ما في شيء واضح لانه خلينا
نقول الو مسك غرد في التغريده وشكله تراجع
او يعني عدل قراره او عمل تزبيط لكلامه
اول شيء قال نحن بدنا نطهر التطهير يعني
انه يخفي الاكونت يخفي الحساب لكن الحذف
الكامل لكن بعدين لما الناس اثاره قضيه
انه هناك بعض الحسابات
لناس قد توفعهم الله وبالتالي هذا المحتوى
لازم يكون موجود هناك فقال
سوف يتم ارشفتها ارشفتها ممكن يضلل
الاكاونت يبقى على تويتر لكن ما في هناك
اي ممكن اتوقع انهم ينشؤوا خاصيه جديده
كما فعلت فيسبوك من قبل بحيث في حال لولا
سمح الله توفى الشخص انه شخص اخر يستلم
الحساب او هذا الحساب يبقى كما هو يعني
الجميع قادر على الاطلاع عليه المستقبل
سيحمل بعض الاهداف ماسك الحقيقيه من وراء
هذا القرار يعني الماسك يقول انه الهدف من
العمليه هو توثيق الحسابات التاكد منها
والتخلص من الحسابات الوهميه التي اتعبت
تويتر لكن في المقابل المختصين يرون انه
السياسه ماسك الجديده الدفع مقابل التوثيق
ادت الى زياده كبيره في الحسابات الوهميه
في تويتر كيف يمكن فهم هذا التناقض
من وجهه نظري متناقض توثيق الحسابات لا
يعني بالضبط التوثيق المعروف اللي هو
العلامه الزرقاء لربما يقصد
ماسكها يعني وجه نظر شرقيه هي التاكد وقال
اتبع كمال لو دخلنا على تغريداته
واتبعنا وافترضنا في الرد كان يقول لازم
نفضي المساحه للحسابات القديمه شو يعني
مثلا فلان عنده حساب او باسمه بس مو قادر
ياخذه لانه شخص ما مقفل هذا الاكونت او
اخذ الاسم وحجزه هذا الموضوع بتعرفي يعني
مسبب مشاكل لكثير مؤسسات حكوميه ومؤسسات
رسميه هو اشخاص اصحاب راي وبالتالي هذا
الشيء ضروري يعني انا انا من وجهه نظري هي
خطوه ضروريه جدا على جميع الاتجاهات ان
شاء الله يعني
القرار النهائي يكون التويتر ولا ماسك فيه
صالح المستخدمين سواء الاحياء منهم ام او
الاموات على الصعيدين
ينتقد هذه السياسات الجديده لماسك ويقول
انه الهدف منها هي جن الايرادات فقط
وتحسين وضع تويتر خصوصا انه بعض العلامات
التجاريه وبعض الاشخاص ابدوا استعدادهم
لدفع الاف الدولارات من اجل شراء حسابات
لاشخاص او حسابات قديمه
هلا قضيه التوثيق قضيه مهمه جدا
يعني اي قرار بيتاخدوا ماسك او غيره راح
يكون في له معارضين ومؤيدين قضيه انه انا
اكون معارض او مؤيد بتحكس مصالح الشخصيه
ما قد يكون مع مصالح الشخصيه قد يخالف
الاخرين لكن انا ارى فينا خطوه جيده لانه
كان معيار التوثيق نوعا ما في نوع من
الضبابيه الان اصبح واضح جدا الان اصبحنا
نعرف انه هذا الحساب فعلا هو حساب رئيسي
للمؤسسه الفلانيه او للوزير الفلاني او
للرئيس الفلاني صار في نوع من الشفافيه في
هذا الموضوع لا ارى
الجهه الثانيه لكن هناك الكثير من الاشخاص
العاديين الذين فقدوا موضوع التوثيق صار
يقول انا ليش لادفع فلوس ما انا كنت متوثق
من الاصل هون صار اللغات الكبير خلينا
نقول الحرب الكلاميه بين اللي كان عنده
حساب متوثق وبين اللي توثق جديد وما كانت
عنده هذه الفرصه من قبل
الاشخاص يشتكون بانه هناك اشخاص اخرين
اشتروا مقابل اسمائهم شكرا من زوم عبر زوم
من دبي انس المراعي متخصص في الشؤون
المعلوماتيه والتقنيه شكرا جزيلا لك انس
[موسيقى]
عيد النصر يوم للتاريخ في روسيا وجمهوريه
الاتحاد السوفيتي يصادف التاسعه من مايو
من كل عام في هذا العام يتم الاحتفال
بالذكرى الثامنه والسبعين للانتصار على
النازيه في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
كالعاده في يوم التاسع من مايو تشهد
الساحه الحمراء في موسكو احتفالا عسكريا
ضخما بمناسبه هذه المناسبات تتشارك معها
في الاحتفال بنفس اليوم اوكرانيا لكن
الاختلاف في هذا العام كان سيد الموقف
فاوكرانيا اختارت الاحتفال في عيد النصر
يوم الثامن من مايو اما روسيا التي كانت
تراهن في حربها باوكرانيا على النصر
فاحتفلت فيه من دون نصر كان رفع المقترح
للبرلمان لتغيير تاريخ عيد النصر الى
الثامن من مايو وقال انه لا يمكن نسيان
المساهمه الكبيره التي قدمتها اوكرانيا في
الانتصار على النازيه لذاك وقال انه من
الان فصاعدا سيكون التاسع من مايو هو يوم
اوروبا في الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي اوكرانيا
وان الاحتفال هذا العام بيوم اوروبا
المكان المثالي للاحتفال بيوم اوروبا اما
الاختلاف في روسيا فكان فقط في تجديد
الاجراءات الامنيه في مكان الاحتفال الذي
انطلق صباح اليوم بحضور الرئيس بلادي في
عرض عسكري ضم عشرات الالاف من الجنود
الروسي شاركت فيه المدرعات والدبابات
الروسيه ومنظومه يارس والعابره للقارات
واسكندر واس 400 لم يغب عن المشهد كذلك
سلاح الجو الروسي لطائرات صخور
[موسيقى]
انتاج كهرباء حلال ممكن ان تعتقد الوهله
الاولى ان هذا العنوان افتراضي ولكن هو
حقيقه واقعيه فالحكومه الاسرائيليه وافقت
على خطه لانشاء شبكه لتخزين الطاقه في
مدنها بهدف انتاج كهرباء متوافقه مع
الشريعه اليهودي او باختصار حلال وبالتالي
يمكن لليهود المتدينين استخدامها ايام
السبت وفق تعاليمهم التي تمنعهم من
استخدام الكهرباء يوم السبت والانشغال
تماما بالعباده في هذا اليوم ففي يوم
السبت عند اليهود المتدينين للكهرباء ولا
سياره ولا تلفاز ولا حتى اجهزه الكترونيه
اما المقصود بخطه تخزين الكهرباء لانتاج
الكهرباء حلال فهو مشروع تجريبي عباره عن
مرافق لتصنيع البطاريات بقدره 24 ميغاوات
تخزن الطاقه الزائده في اوقات ذروه
الانتاج وتستفيد منها نحو 3000 اسره
وستتول شركه الكهرباء الاسرائيليه
المملوكه للدوله بناء المرفق بتكلفه تصل
الى 33
مليون دولار
[موسيقى]
في حادثه غريبه ونادره الوقوع وتضاف الى
قائمه الحوادث المروعه على متن الرحلات
الجويه تعرضت راكبه للدغه ملعقرب وهي
علمتني رحله جويه على متن شركه طيران
الهند كانت متجهه من الجبور الى مومباي في
الهند في التفاصيل قالت الشركه في بيان
لها بان الركبه تعرضت للدغ من قبل عقرب
كان على متن هذه الطائره تمت معالجه
المسافره بشكل طارئ على متن الرحله وتم
نقلها الى المستشفى بعد هبوط الطائره
وخرجت في وقت لاحق من المستشفى بصحه جيده
اكدت ان هذه الحادثه نادره ومؤسفه وان
فريق شركه الطيران اتبع البروتوكول واجرى
فحصا كاملا للطائره وجد العقرب بعد ذلك تم
تنفيذ عمليه التبخير وتطهير وعبرت الشركه
عن اسرها على المعاناه والازعاج الذي لحق
بالمسافره
في امان الله
[موسيقى]